[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben ich sehe im moment
überall diesen trend und deswegen wollte
ich auch meinen teil dazu beitragen und
zeigt euch heute einen zu versüßen
unicorn magic zuallererst bereite ich
doch horn vor und dafür nehme ich wie im
video gesehen etwas von land und wolle
ihn längst aus um ihn dann in der mitte
zu falten und dann aufzurollen
achtet insbesondere darauf dass oben
alles sehr spitz ist und nach unten hin
immer dicker verläuft jetzt nehme ich
mir einen strohhalm und spielformen
daran aus und dafür dass man vollständig
auswerten
anschließend wird das einmal mit
goldener lebensmittel farbe angemalt ich
verlinke euch die noch mal in die
infobox die könnt ihr unverdünnt
auftragen und anschließend nochmal
trocknen lassen solange kümmere ich mich
um die ohren mit einräumen dafür brauche
ich weißen und rosa vom land und den
gebe ich jetzt auch ein bisschen besser
stärker auf meine arbeitsfläche
überdachte seite folie drauf und
schneide mir dann dreiecke aus und die
frischhaltefolie dient dazu dass die
kanten etwas weicher ausgeschnitten
werden
jetzt schaue ich kurz auf das beides
optisch zusammenpasst und wenn das der
fall ist dann nehme ich mir etwas wasser
auf mein pinsel gibt das auf den weißen
fondant gebe dann ein zahnstocher da
rein und klebe den rosen fondant darüber
unsere guter letzt gebe ich da mit den
händen noch etwas vom rhein in dem ich
das etwas nach innen knicke und lasters
austrocknen
anschließend gebe ich in die mitte der
ohren noch einen kleinen goldenen akzent
im nächsten schritt die krise ich mein
glas dafür tauglich den flaschenhals in
geschmolzene weiße kuvertüre und lass
ihn sehr lange abtropfen und im
anschluss kommt das glas dann in die
bunten streuseln
das geld gebe ich hätte für zehn minuten
in den tiefkühler und mache so lange
weiter mit den menschen
wir brauchen 400 milliliter milch und
flüchten er per 1
die beiden flut haben werden jetzt
einfach miteinander verlinkt
das war auch erst meine menschen die wie
ich bis zur weiterverarbeitung in den
kühlschrank kümmere mich in der
zwischenzeit um die weitere deko dafür
brauche ich herrn zuckerrübensirup bunte
streusel und pinkel im für das habe es
gebe ich etwas von der lebensmittelfarbe
in meinen zuckerrübensirup und wir
müssen das so lange bis mir die farbe
gefällt
anschließend gebe ich dann noch etwa von
stolzen hinein und vermittelt auf ganze
nochmal jetzt nämlich mithilfe mainspitz
beutel mit einer langen loch hülle und
fülle dann den sirup hinein und damit
werden jetzt im inneren des clusters am
rand ein paar linien hinaufgeflogen und
[Musik]
jetzt fühle ich den weg ins klar
und für die finale dekoration habe ich
noch einmal frische sahne aufgeschlagen
habe sie ihm einen spritzbeutel mit
einer faschingsfeier tipp gegeben und
spritzte das ganze einmal auf und schaut
mal wie schön dass mutter ist wahnsinn
wenn die möchte ich natürlich dazu noch
mal ein extra video und da gebe ich noch
mal sprüche drauf dann kommt der
vornhinein und auch die ohren und fertig
ist unser unicorn eschwege falls ihr
euch diesen weg jetzt gehen wollt oder
falls sie einen liebsten eine freude
machen möchte dann macht gerne nach ich
freue mich von euch zu hören
entweder in den kommentaren auf youtube
oder auch im programm
bis zum nächsten mal auf s kitchen